[Musik]
doch lehtinen präsentiert vom toyota
yaris dem kleinsten vollhybrid
[Musik]
egal kommt ihr zum kino willkommen beim
clean up nummer 118 wenn ich mich nicht
irre
wir waren am montag aus zu den anderen
inseln um aufzuräumen
wir nehmen gleich das boot nach collect
eine entlarvte er nie jemand geliebt hat
aber er werde dennoch ab waren am strand
finden
schaut euch an was es ist und woher wir
wollen euch zeigen dass abfall ein
globales problem ist jeden montag
spielen sich solche szenen ab am stand
von kolibri einer kleinen ferieninsel im
äußersten süden thaila
die schweizer barrios atelier und roman
peter brechen mit touristen und
einheimischen auf um gemeinsam einen
strand zu sein
die freiwilligen sollen mit eigenen
augen sehen wie sich die globale müll
flut auswirkt und so kassierer serie
also abfall hätten
[Musik]
rund um coaching mehrere unbewohnte
insel verstreut die ein
naturschutzgebiet werden
von weitem betrachtet nichts als
unberührte strände doch der eindruck
täuscht
die haben sich ungebetene gäste breit
gemacht und die zuschauer sind gekommen
um diese zu vertrauen
das unterholz hinter dem strand ist
übersät mit abfall vor allem plastik und
styropor werden hier angeschwemmt das
mea schreckt berger vom
zivilisationsmüll auf die unbewohnten
insel
[Musik]
ein dauerbrenner beim strandgut flip
flops in reihe zwei minuten trieb schon
witzig sein wäre das tief sind flip
fernanda hätten wiederum die schüler von
anderen mietern aber fußball-klasse
schönsten rezepte und viele dieser pet
flaschen sind weit gereist
[Musik]
einige der helfer leben auf der insel
und sind regelmäßig bei den clean up
dabei und auch die real time wie die
auto liebe stationiert ist schickt immer
wieder soldaten zum aufräumen eindruck
durchgehend vor allem für sein buch oder
schlafen verrußte fertig bist du denn
heute türen und umgang mit luxus zu
richten
zur arbeit kamen unter druck so dass man
wirklich noch zusammenbekommen die
einfache botschaft dass man gemeinsam
etwas erreichen kann kommt bei den
touristen an
es ist ein versuchen müller bietet mit
ihrer musik und wenn man alle thema tief
in eine gelöst sind kann aber schnell
gehen und zwei wochen am strand liegen
kann kann auch mal ein treffen
die einheimischen bootsführer werden für
die ausfahrten bezahlt ansonsten gilt
der grundsatz niemand verdient etwas als
kassierer der lohn für die mühen ist ein
gemeinsames erfolgserlebnis das sich so
niemand bereichern kann ist in thailand
ein wichtiger faktor für die
glaubwürdigkeit der gesammelte abfall
wird nach polizei gebracht
die einzige bewohnte insel des kleinen
artikels ist winzig und erst in den
letzten jahren vom tourismus richtig
entdeckt worden
heute lässt sich in der hochsaison von
drei bis viertausend leuten bevölkert
eine systematische abfallentsorgung mit
recycling ist erst seit den letzten paar
jahren im aufbau das strandbad wird auf
kohle gesammelt sortiert und schließlich
auf das festland verpachtet
moskau verwahrte wirtschaft und kleiner
kleinstein deponie vor dem regal blieb
währenddessen nimmt das touristen leben
seinen gewohnten gang
nicht alle gäste auf der insel nehmen
die abfall helden war so gutes und
sprich darüber gilt derzeit auch für
träsch eine weitere grundregel lautet
jede aufräumaktion muss auf facebook mit
fotos und filmen dokumentiert werden
die taktik und sei los und hatte sich
facebook-gründer und deutschland genau
da die ermittler beschrieben
ich kann machen was ich da welche bilder
auf facebook landen will aber sorgfältig
ausgewählt sein
eigentlich ist es relativ kühl ich mit
bildet vorab aus wo nicht schön aus fern
aber mit händen wunder zum die schwache
message wird mit dem das mit positiven
nachrichten positiven möglichkeiten
gelöst oder unglücklicher krediten sage
new classic und sterben des schon fünf
nach zwölf ist alles noch nicht verloren
sondern mache ich nicht
[Musik]
oli p ein schlechtes image als dreckige
indes allein das will niemand schon gar
nicht diejenigen die vom tourismus lebt
dazu gehört auch darius vakili er lebt
seit 15 jahren auf der insel und die
zeit mit seiner ehefrau wie ein
restaurant und hoffte
[Musik]
hier im café liepe gründete darius 2013
mit roman peter und drei anderen
schweizern wie damals länger auf der
insel waren dem verein über den verein
können sie in der schweiz spendengelder
sammeln
barrios muss class hero an seinem
eigenen betrieb vorbei manövrieren wo er
jeden montag wegen der trainer fred
rutten relativ glück stellte ihr
eigentlicher großteil machen aber er
stand jeden morgen um halb sieben
morgens dass gottes und sich dann alle
zu machen eine schnelle motive tobe ein
18 monats macht zwischen trieben so
kriegen wir finden unser gott oder
sturmhaube
andrä
wenn die sonne untergeht beginnt roman
arbeitstag in der elefanten spielt er
als musiker in der karaoke welt
[Musik]
für diesen job hat er ein arbeitsvisum
das es ihm erlaubt monatelang in
thailand zu bleiben
[Musik]
1013 blieb wo man auf einer weltreise uk
seither verbringt die wintermonate
durchgehend auf die linke mit dem
[Applaus]
[Musik]
zwei stunden vor sonnenaufgang ist
darius bereits wieder auf den beinen
erste amtshandlung den unvermeidlichen
eigenen abfall für die müllabfuhr
bereitstellen
dann ist es zeit den brotteig zu mischen
es ist kurz nach 4
[Musik]
pünktlich um 5 kommt unüberhörbar die
müllabfuhr
juli
[Musik]
auf der anderen seite der insel beginnt
romans tag jeweils mit yoga er wohnt in
einem kleinen bungalow wenig platz da
für direkte mehr sicht
[Musik]
diesen winter verbringt der romand
freundin dorit auf polizei zur freude
der nachbarskinder
[Musik]
doch das idyllische leben dass touristen
hier finden hat seinen preis
jede wasserflasche auf colibri muss vom
festland auf die insel verschifft werden
um den verbrauch von pet-flaschen
einzudämmen hat zwei trinkflaschen auf
metall herstellen lassen und die musik
für lonza und gewitter der mosel und der
kommenden januar class hero gibt die
flaschen hotels und geschäften zum
selbstkostenpreis ab diese können sie
dann mit einem gewinn an touristen
verkaufen
für rund 6 franken allerdings sind
bedingungen daran geknüpft
im jahr gezogen die kleine station
gratis war der ab jetzt das heißt also
fällt aber mit der prämierung artikel
oder meinen finger locker zu
restaurieren der vaart einen roboter und
die alpha beta oder rufen sie die
flasche bestehende gepostet die walking
street ist die hauptschlagader die quer
durch qualitäten
hier reihen sich geschäfte bars und
tauchschulen aneinander
und überall sind mittlerweile
wasserspender für die metall klassen zu
finden wo das system haben das ist
wirklich ein mikrofon wird die elefanten
etwa verkauft überhaupt kein wasser mehr
in plastikflaschen
mehrere hotels stellen bereits metall
flaschen und die zimmer und sparen es
nicht so den gästen jeden tag zwei
frische pet-flaschen liefern zu müssen
dass wir ein problem mit abfall und
plastikmüll haben aber die leichten de
anfordern wären für enel um gier zu rät
sich noch weniger entwickelten ideen das
problem bekommen andere internet ein
foto
die meisten diskutieren die
wiederverwendbaren flaschen entfernt
wäre
alle hotels auf der insel mit metall
flaschen auszustatten
die idee von fresh hero hat sich
mittlerweile über pro liter hinaus
ausgebreitet
an einem dutzend orten in thailand aber
auch in indonesien und malaysia haben
sich ableger gegründet
roman ist auf das festland gefahren um
die badeorte andere teams kennenzulernen
vertreter aus sechs orten in thailand
sind zusammengekommen
weil sich die idee vor allem per
internet verbreitet hat roman viele
seiner mitstreiter noch gar nie
persönlich getroffen
ich könnt ihr über facebook oder über
das telefon und auch mit einem kontakt
mit augen- frauen- und riley mit
downloads natürlich verständlich die
gerichte sehen dass dort mit leib und
seele mit nach hause bieten und die
persönlichen kontakte sollen das
zusammengehörigkeitsgefühl noch mehr
stärken
am nächsten tag gibt es natürlich eine
aufräumaktion am strand von anna
angeführt vom lokalen ableger von
kaschirow einem sogenannten klagte hier
setzen die organisatorinnen noch mehr
als in politik
auf die beteiligung der einheimischen
[Musik]
wir versuchen ja auch lokalen geschäften
und hotels einzubeziehen
die schalen wir wollen dass alle ein
verantwortungsgefühl sie diesen ort
entwickeln wo man freut sich über das
wachstum der situation aber auch als
eine marke die führung braucht wer den
namen verwenden will sich an regeln
halten
so müssen aufräumaktionen wöchentlich an
einem fixen tag stattfinden
denn das zeigt wirkung haben vor etwas
mehr als einem jahr angefangen die leute
haben gesehen dass sie das jede woche
machen
darum werden wir ernst genommen auch von
regierungen
doch wie viele regeln muss es überhaupt
geben wie groß soll die selbstbestimmung
der einzelnen schaffte sein wie viel
kontrolle geständig darüber sind sich
die trassierung gründer nicht einig die
ausgangslage ist für jeden auf anders in
olang etwa wird wenig müll angespült den
abfall produzieren hier vor allem die
benutzer des strandes
eine spannende story touristen am strand
liegen eigentlich zwischen gudrun auch
auf diese weise kommt genug müll
zusammen
ja
männer
für manche fundstücke gibt das recycling
idee ein flash hero aus pattani hat
80.000 angespülte flip flops aus kohle
übernommen
schrader sie und stellt daraus neue flip
flop das soll gleich noch arbeitsplätze
schaffen wir haben hier eine kleine
mobile einheit
damit könnte in zukunft einheimische in
den touristenzentren die schuhe gleich
vor ort herstellen und verkaufen auch
solche projekte sind ein schritt in
richtung romandie das kaschirow zu einer
ernstzunehmenden stimme heranwächst
wir hoffen dass sich roman ein
einheitliches auftreten aller travel
möglichst weltweit
darius glaubt hingegen nicht dass man
beliebig viele orte über einen kamm
scheren kann sondern jeder lokal
passende rezepte für das abfallproblem
finden muss auf colibri ist in den
letzten jahren eine entsorgungsstation
aufgebaut worden
hier landet der müll von dem clean up
und von der insel
da wird alles von ebay aufgaben frösche
fotos auf die heimspringen ihrem lager
so viel kraft und größe zeigen flasche
eine der zahlreichen bars auf der insel
führt die raffgier ist seit dem ersten
clean up mit dabei und für class hero
eine wichtige stimme wenn es um die
sensibilisierung der einheimischen geht
jetzt nahtlos als großes stadtschloss
vor der aufführung festland
gepresste pet flaschen oder büchsen
können auf dem feld land an
recyclingfirmen verkauft werden früh ist
sehr locker machen will und er findet
ein umdenken findet statt
doch je mehr der tourismus anzieht auf
der insel desto größer werden auch hier
die abfallberge
in wien in luzerner willert hier ist
roman während der sommermonate zu hause
und bemüht sich um neue spenden für den
verein mit musikalischen mitteln ein
benefiz konzerte freundin ina müller
etwa kommt aus dem nachbardorf und kennt
roman und rasch iro schon seit jahren an
flotten große rote fleck so viel über
das ist der stigmatisierung dass knochen
theater höchst einfach genau da steht
einem hofgrundstück 550 meter 25 06
damit sucht er die hilfe willkommen
ich freue mich sehr dass kommt am
richtigen ort oder am freitag zu
verdanken der musiker hat das wasser
nachlaufen
das benefizkonzert zeigt bei publikum
und auch bei den künstlern für roman ist
es ein heimspiel
er kennt hier beinahe alle und identität
angenommen es zuvor auf die projekte vor
wind und sichert diese belasteten herz
von porsche besser
am schluss kommen sogar 8000 franken
zusammen für clean up trinkflaschen oder
t shirts
[Musik]
darum ist unterwegs zu einem augenschein
auf der intel core raten im naturschutz
gibt
diese idyllische buchten die class
heroes so vermüllt vor dass sie 2040
entkernt einrichteten
wo freiwillige einen monat am stück
ausmisten 80.000 flip flop sammelten sie
61.000 pet-flaschen aber sauber ist es
noch lange nicht
die behandlung spielt hier den abfall
mehrere meter tief in den dschungel
hinein
warner home office ist eine vertiefung
styropor wieder anders schön separiert
unglück immer noch gut meldungen haben
sich vor augen führt dass diese droge
schindler programmen straße behalten der
tropischen insel
und relativ kostengünstig cabo de mit
ein anblick der hoffnungslos stimmen
könnte mit öffnet aufgerufen dann verlor
man vielleicht eher zur verlor beruf
geben das funktioniert in 50 jahren mit
dass gott nicht dass deutschland so gut
wie das logo doch wie soll man dieses
werkzeug einsetzen es jedem der hierher
kommt mit geben oder aktiv in die welt
hinaustragen romans mission für die nach
polen
nach brods war auch bekannt als breslau
in der viertgrößten stadt polens
betreibt die credit suisse and back
office center mit 3000 mitarbeitern
einer davon agatha sasic hat den collie
pentling ab mitgemacht
seither setzte sich in der firma für
abfallvermeidung im arbeitsalltag ein
homann ist eingeladen worden
das hero credit suisse management
vorzustellen am besten gleich auf dem
weg zum aufräumen einer ausflugs insel
in der oder
die banker lassen sich beeindruckt von
den bildern des kerns in kurabi
das sieht man auf den bieter nicht
einmal der abfahrt steht knietief und
reicht noch 40 zentimeter in den boden
das liegt hier zum teil schon seit zehn
oder 20 jahren
agatha und roman heben die idee die
credit suisse belegschaft in groß was
mit wasserflaschen auszustatten und
internet sind sind interessiert an der
flasche vielleicht seid ihren ferien in
coldplay hat agata schon mehrere clean
up mit der firma organisiert ein kollege
habe ich realisiert dass es nicht reicht
an einem montag einmal aufräumen sondern
ob man seine einstellung ändern muss
deshalb wollte ich die idee hier in
polen weiter und so betätigen sich dank
einer idee von schweizern in thailand
ein dutzend banker in polen als müller
vor
[Musik]
was wiederum per facebook weitere leute
inspirieren könnte und vielleicht kann
der direkte kontakt in polen auch
weitere türen in den großbanken eine
beatbox linien von männer zu welcher das
vor gut
deshalb mache ja und heute ganz großen
bildschirm mit der chefin auch dieser
ist fleißig und sehr zugeneigt extrem
gut auf die aktion reagiert es ist eine
total simpel aber effektiv bekennt sich
erst eine credit suisse mit tirol zur
abfallvermeidung könnten andere
großfirmen folgen hofft rom an
nächste station london wo man kann
zusammen mit tino einen umweltpreis
abholen überreicht von einer tochter des
thailändischen königs auch in london
gebe es noch abfall einzusammeln
doch ein clean up muss vorerst war
im rahmen einer tourismusmesse wird
jährlich der thai green exzellenz award
verliehen
für die begegnung mit der prinzessin
bekommt bio genaue instruktionen und
verhaltensregeln stehen sie aus sich
nicht umgehen sie einfach rückwärts
und dann gehen sie zurück zu ihrem platz
und es reicht auch nicht ausnahmsweise
ein t shirt zu tragen
das kitz ist pflicht
prinzessin born hat anna ist die älteste
tochter des 2016 verstorbenen königs
bhumibol der in thailand über alle maßen
verehrt wurde
entsprechend groß ist die ehrfurcht
ihrer anwesenden landsleute
bei gefühlten
als kritik
es geht
[Applaus]
platz
er hatte
nach der kurzen begegnung in der bio
sichtlich erleichtert
[Musik]
ich war etwas nervös aber jetzt von mir
dieser ausflug nach london wird
allerdings ein nachspiel haben
[Musik]
man hat wieder sein hängematten büro auf
colibri bezogen
in new york will gerade ein paar ein
chirurg zu gründen aber in class hero
verein haben sich gräben aufgetan
zwischen roma auf der einen seite und
darius mit den restlichen drei
vorstandsmitgliedern im hintergrund auf
der anderen die finanzierung die
ausreise nach london ist zu
prinzipienfrage geworden dass ich
entscheide mich dass mit vergoldet und
ich bin quasi vor vollendete tatsachen
gestellt wurde
und für mich ist es natürlich so und
benefizkonzert und spendenbriefe wieder
spenden versprechen ab messe für buch
und prozent seiner projektchor und 35
prozent der spenden für einen flug
zahlen und das gar nicht unterschrieben
der rest des vorstands vertritt die
ansicht dass die ausreise der 24 uhr
sache dient und somit den spendenzweck
erfüllt weil man sich nicht einigen kann
sagt roman die reise schließlich auf
seinem privaten budget auch über die
finanzierung von projekten außerhalb co
lieb es wird man sich nicht ein roman
sucht das internationale wachstum
die anderen wollen ihre kräfte und das
geld lieber auf politik konzentrieren
[Musik]
sparmöglichkeit kunde mit sprüchen klar
unter den ist ein pokerspiel flügen
wieder vorhin ganz eigenen handy der
letzte zug oder gar nicht wieso sachen
entscheiden obwohl sie gar nicht im
projekt wir sind so stark wachsen noch
richtig explodiert und die struktur
passt und das garagentor und anderen
mitteln und wegen des mords an oder so
wurde und das gibt immer und ich muss es
zu einem punkt wo man seit gut bekommt
mächtig und ihr werdet ihr richtig und
weise funktionieren
12 bis 15 stunden in der woche
das ist 100 die 100 stunden woche als
ich schon aus drangen dann ist das alles
ein und zahlen zur b 3 das ist halt
letztlich in einer beziehung lebt und
bekommt recht ist immer größer und
größer wurde bist du mein volk traue ich
mir zu sagen wenn wir so wie zehnt und
wenn die sache wurde sind mit dem kann
ich mich nicht identifizieren
er muss zurücktreten ich persönlich
finde natürlich schade wenn man das
eigentlich als linker oder freunde das
projekt gestartet hat ich immer noch
schwer auf das eigentliche lösung
[Musik]
doch die stimmung auf colibri ist
nachhaltig verdorben
[Musik]
mm
roman ist aus dem verein ausgetreten
aber nie um zwei euro den rücken zu
kehren
er gründet kurzerhand seinen eigenen
verein unter dem namen class hero world
will er unabhängig von den anderen
weitermachen nach seinen eigenen
spielregeln
damit ist der bruch besiegelt
die abfall helden gehen getrennte wege
der betrieb ist oder nicht wenn dies für
den monat mit einer ganz oder gar nicht
das ist ein moment
[Musik]
einige monate später roman ist am
netzwerken
seit er zurück in der schweiz ist knüpft
er intensiv kontakte mit internationalen
und schweizer umweltorganisationen wie
außen kehrt der tatendrang beziehen in
der schweiz nicht abhanden gekommen
momentan ist es jedoch sechs tage woche
durch ein tage der woche noch geschafft
das ist für ihn grün ihre computer
aber das ist momentan so viel
beschäftigen öffentliche gelder mit
großsponsoren zusammenbringen
die stelle wo man will künftig als
geschäftsführer einen lohn beziehen
damit fällt der grundsatz dass niemand
mit ihr geld verdient im wachstum zum 8
am ufer des luzerner lebe im findet
roland schweizer abfall helden der
verein schweizer umwelt- und abfall
taura seubert seit jahren wöchentlich
schweizer sehen
[Musik]
wenn die letzten kursschiffe abgelegt
haben können die taucher gefahrlos
arbeit
auch das hafenbecken vor dem kkl ist
eine fundgrube für abfall der achtlos
ins wasser geworfen wird
[Musik]
als gründer thomas niederer sieht in den
vermeintlich sauberen schweizer
gewässern erschreckendes material
das meine letzte aktion die 300 tonnen
zellstoff 12 wo soll ich mir sehr gut an
das make-up dort monatlich höchstens auf
immerhin zeigt dass situation
stock die unterwasser expedition bringt
erstaunliche fundstücke aus dem
hafenbecken anfragen einheben foto auch
am vierwaldstättersee pflicht aber roman
will noch einen schritt weiter gehen
er zieht auch gegen unsichtbaren
plastikmüll ins feld und sucht
verbündete in der politik in triska
birrer heimo nationalrätin und
präsidentin der stiftung für
konsumentenschutz hat er eine
interessierte zuhörerin gefunden ich bin
mit der art der schnell das wort thema
für die mehrheit der freundliche ältere
und hatte die einzelnen produkten
kräftig drauf los und biete kräftig hat
seine machen das wirklich ihr produkt
dafür mit sich mit der sie den hof
logisch
die derart zum beispiel projekt problem
vorliegt
sie können vielleicht möchten sie bitten
plastik weg kein wunder ich habe mit so
einfach wichtige projekte zu bringen
aber wenig sinnvoll der wartburg und
probieren oder wäre nicht probiert so
verloren oder so ich eigentlich
betrachtet teststunden und jetzt durch
über die gegenfahrbahn
die produktion oder in der hand der eine
wird geladen
theoretische konzepte und was eine
weitere tranche flasche ist an die frau
gebracht
es ist nicht die letzte an diesem abend
beim filmfest des architekturbüros gegen
luzern bekommen alle mitarbeiter ihre
persönliche flasche
dafür werden pet lunchboxen und
einweggeschirr aus dem büro verband und
das network of workers am arbeitsplatz
das heißt firmenmotto eigene musik
produziert offenes minimum zu reduzieren
während hier quasi das erste schweizer
botschafter gestalt annimmt ist roman
verbindung zum gründungsort komitee
abgriffen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
darf ich endlich das gift
das ist so und mit dem dank richtete mit
800 m große erwartungen wecken und so
viel an die 9 58 uhr und ich bin alt
wien begonnen
im lied wie das macht auch einen großen
und es ist kurz ist es stärkste richtige
schritte zu liebe und sorge dass das
wirkliche problem auf
[Musik]
mittlerweile gibt es weltweit 30 träsch
hero schafft er's die hälfte davon in
tyler die restlichen in indonesien
myanmar malaysia auf den philippinen und
park und new york rund 21.000 leute
haben schon an klima preisen
auch goalie pgm darius und bio weiterhin
jeden montag aufräumen sie organisieren
sich selbstständig auf der insel
für mich persönlich ist es auch wie hoch
die mieten motiviert möglich zu machen
muss um alte ladens vater dort machen
für zukünftige generationen
trotz ihrer differenzen letztendlich
ziehen die helden des abfalls alle am
selben strick
[Musik]
dort wurde ihnen präsentiert vom toyota
yaris dem kleinsten vollhybrid